biomics is now branded with inflation
particularly around housing energy and
protein food there's $2 trillion of free
money coming in the chips and science
Act and the inflation reduction act
that's extraordinarily inflationary not
a cent has been spent yet so the risk
bomic has if you want to tie those two
programs to bomic and you have to those
are his programs is when you turn that
crank of free money from the helicopter
you get that inflation back at you right
in the middle of campaign next year
which is why I think and it's my own
personal forecast another 50 basis
points ratees from the FED hi Mr
Wonderful here and I am small business
does your company qualify for the
employee retention credit find out at
Wonder trust.com educate yourself with a
live expert at Wonder trust now because
the ERC program is going to end soon